every everybody now is obviously
bitcoin is crashed we have the
convention coming up it has lost half of
its value
um roughly half of its value where is it
right now about 35 000.
great and we all know that we've been
on this uh we've been riding this
economic
um you know train
here at high speed for well over a
decade
i mean this is one of the biggest bull
markets in history for the longest
amounts of time
a lot of people said that it speculated
it should have ended pre-coveted
but covid uh just allowed the government
to print money and artificially
subsidize everybody's lives
uh their new homes their you know cheap
interest rates
you know put money into the economy
stimulus blah blah blah
and then eventually this is all coming
to an end
every financial show now literally
introduces every guest like this you're
like
uh ladies and gentlemen our next guest
says that the entire world
the entire world economy will be
destroyed within 72 hours give it up for
peter schiff and then
peter schiff comes out and he's like you
know literally and i like
petership he's this libertarian who
lives in puerto rico who gets
hard every time the economy's about to
tank every time there's about to be like
a serious tip peter shifts on every show
talking about stagflation he loves it he
just start he gets
we want him on here let's get him
somebody email peter schiff
um we want him on here uh he does not
like bitcoin
he's a big gold guy he goes [ __ ] bitcoin
it'll never be gold i wanted to bring
him
to the bitcoin convention and have him
just screaming at the people and have
them booing him being like [ __ ] you and
he's like it'll never be gold and
they're like boo
but that's every financial story right
now is that it's gonna end and nobody
really knows when it's gonna end
that's what keeps people up at night
they go
when is this gonna and how bad is it
gonna be when it falls apart
i mean if you get some of these uh
articles
up i mean literally the youtube
thumbnails are like i think peter schiff
has one where it goes people will lose
everything
um i'll just type that in you know
you know dent i forget his first name
yeah the crash is going to come sooner
than you think
a new crisis is coming i mean
this is a planned economic collapse
please
save yourself it's going to crash sooner
than you think
i mean he's going to start selling merch
soon that just says crash
the final financial crisis yeah the
final financial crisis
i mean it's just please save yourself
prepare
the worst crisis of your lifetime i mean
he's he's his brand is like
because the thing about these guys and
listen he's gonna be right eventually
like one day it is gonna happen
but until it happens you gotta keep
saying it's gonna happen like there was
a great quote where it's like peter
schiff
has predicted nine out of the last two
recessions
like he just doesn't stop but that's the
libertarian like austrian economist
gold standard guys and i get it but
they're always like
it's coming and it's gonna be bad
and when it comes whoa
stock market's gonna go to zero like
there goes some of these guys
some of these they just they they're
literally it's just like
stock market's going to go to zero so if
you want to learn how to save yourself
sign up for the thing that i am selling
now you might think to yourself hey if
the stock market goes to zero
and we go back to a barter economy
nothing in your newsletter is really
gonna help me you might have that
thought
you might have the thought that like i
don't know last summer people couldn't
work for a while
uh the cops did some [ __ ] up [ __ ] and
there was a month
of riots when we still had food and
some of us still had money so you'd
imagine at stock market
zero with nothing going on
your newsletter isn't really going to
make it all okay you'd imagine it would
get pretty bad pretty quickly
you know uh it would be like i am legend
overnight but if you want to know what
to happens in that situation if you want
to know how to
protect yourself and your assets sign up
for my newsletter
where are you typing your newsletter
from when they stormed the house